what's he done now I'll just write you a
check for whatever you took we just need
to talk to me here the cops are here
again guess what I didn't do anything
I've been here all day
yes relax Peter we're not cops ocean
that cops we were cops you wouldn't be
driving a rental car how'd you know
we've got a rental car check your
registration when you were walking
through the door I also had some time to
kill so I went through your rental
agreements are you from out of town we I
know you're not cops it was with this
gifted youngsters place
that's an old cult he's fascinating he's
a pain in the ass what a teleporter no
he says fast but I know me what's a soul
young young you just old
so you're not afraid to show your powers
powers what powers what are you talking
about you see something strange here
nothing anybody would believe if he told
them so who are you what do you want
we need your help Peter what break into
a highly secured facility and to get
someone out Prison Break that's illegal
you know
only if you get caught so what's in it
for me you kleptomaniac get to break
into the Pentagon
how do I know I can trust you because
we're just like you Sharon
it's cool
you